this is [ __ ] 20 years of putting out  a ton of [ __ ] love asking for nothing  it doesn't happen like that so i think  the way you have to do is build a  community like where's the discord for  the project it's  ready it's not live yet that's the reps  that's like thinking about doing  push-ups you're gonna have to do them  right in terms of the push-ups for the  discord any specific advice yeah launch  a discord and then [ __ ] put out a  tweet and be like yo join my discord and  three people show up because you only  have 200 followers you know and it's  just [ __ ] step by step step by step  but it takes time okay to get to a place  to sell 10 000 units of something  takes like time